joanna we need your expert eye on this
next story because it comes from real
homes they're reporting that there's one
design trend in 2022 that they're going
to flip a switch on and that's shiplap
boom
the designer said that the ship has
sailed on shiplap it's trying to time to
try something different a wallpaper and
said now joanna you literally changed
shiplap for everybody you put it on the
map you made it
a material we all i just did it in a
room and it's my favorite thing i've
ever done in my life i think shiplap you
know when you think about it this is
something that's been in homes for over
a hundred years so to me
trend again i'm not a trendy person
that's what when you get stuck in a
trend it's like oh i like more that idea
of timeless back to the basics so when i
think about shiplap or even hardwood
floors or certain kinds of tile that
have been around for over 100 years i
just don't think that's really something
that ever goes out now i get that it's
been done a lot in that farmhouse kind
of genre but what i think the trend is
is seeing how that's going to cross over
to multiple different styles whether
it's modern or minimal you're going to
see it kind of do it's saying in all
different kinds of styles because it's a
classic material it's how they used to
build homes so to me it's like you can't
it's timeless it's not going to i love
it i also think it goes to your point it
goes with everything and if someone says
a drywall or a shiplap there's no
question yeah and you can hang it you
can go for it
vertical you can you can be creative
with how you install it and that's the
fun part is seeing how it's evolving so
and i like that
all right and it wouldn't be a proper
true news without the snacks you know
we've always got some a magnolia
approved grub today in what we call food
news
what is this
mac and cheese sandwich what
so now these are from the cheddar truck
they've made us these cheesy sandwiches
i got made of joe and i's collective
dreams it's a classic grilled cheese
with two types of cheeses but get ready
for this twist there is mac and cheese
in here
so oh cheddar box
for literally sending me right over the
edge so i will tell you if there was any
debate about whether or not there was a
god or not you've got it i have a
mac and cheese sandwich and i think it i
think it's oh my god there's cheese on
the outside outside
everywhere this is my dream holy moly
drew you managed to make mac and cheese
worse for me
by putting it in a grilled cheese i'll
never forgive you this is so good
you guys are just so amazing
[Music]